SHANEE NISHRY: Making
virtual reality games
and applications
with Unity is easy.
In this video I'll go over the
concepts and implementation
of adding Cardboard
support to a Unity project.
As you may know,
Unity is a game engine
with an editor that allows you
to easily import 3-D models
and arrange them in the scene.
You can also attach
scripts to objects
to give them functionality.
Before we start, make sure
to get the Cardboard Unity
plugin from this link.
Then, open your Unity project
and import a package like this.
Now that they are all set, there
are two things you need to do.
You need to create a
stereoscopic camera
and make sure your user
interface works well
for virtual reality.
Let's start with adding the
camera and look into modifying
the UI at the end.
You can do so by using one of
the available prefabbed objects
or by attaching a script
to an existing camera.
The easiest way is to use
the Cardboard main prefab.
This is best if you're
starting a new project
or haven't made any changes
to your existing camera.
Simply replace the existing
camera with the Cardboard
main prefab, and you're done.
You can still add any
custom scripts on top,
for controlling the
camera, for example.
Press Play, and you'll have
a functioning scopic view.
You can rotate the
camera using the Alt key
while moving the mouse.
To simulate Cardboard Trego,
press the left mouse button.
If you already
have a camera, you
can use the Cardboard
adapter prefab.
Add it as a child of
your camera and select
Update Stereo Cameras
from the Components menu.
Once again, you can
press Play and have
a functioning stereoscopic
view in the game window.
If you don't want
to use a prefab,
then you can just use a script.
By adding the stereo controller
script to your camera,
two stereoscopic cameras
will be created dynamically
as you press play.
You may not want to use the
stereo controller script
since it doesn't let you add
any image processing on top
of the cameras because
they are added dynamically.
If you want to create the
cameras in the Editor,
then simply select Update
Stereo Cameras from the menu
and they will be
created for you.
Press Play, and you are done.
Last thing we have to do is
get the user interface working
and add support for the Trego.
Start by adding the
[INAUDIBLE] Input Module script
to the [INAUDIBLE]
Event System Object.
This script emits [INAUDIBLE]
for the event system
based on the user's gaze.
Next, in your UI element, set
the Conference Render mode
to [INAUDIBLE] Space
and set the event camera
to a camera controlled by
a Cardboard head script,
either directly or as a parent.
At this point, the system is
able to respond to the user's
gaze into triggers so that
UI elements, such as buttons,
can be activated.
If you wish to interact with
3-D objects in the scene,
add a physics ray caster
component to the event camera.
Designate an in-game
object to be interactive
by adding a collider component
to interact with the ray
caster.
And by adding a
script to respond
to the generated events.
An event trigger
is a good choice,
or you can implement some of the
standard Unity event interfaces
on your own scripts.
If you wish to add a
cursor to let a user see
the point of their gaze, set
the Gaze Input models cursor
to the game object that
will serve [INAUDIBLE].
This cursor will be moved to
the exact point on whatever UI
object the user is gazing at.
If the event camera has
a physics ray caster,
then this includes 3-D objects
with the collider components.
If no object is hit by a ray
cast, the cursor is hidden.
Now that you know how
to make everything work,
it is important to keep in mind
some best practices in order
to make a compelling
virtual reality experience.
The three most important
words to remember
are always keep tracking
on, keep stable 60 frames
per second or higher, and
avoid unexpected motion.
One of the things that makes
virtual reality compelling
is the ability to look around.
In contrast, it would
feel extremely unnatural
if the camera stopped
responding to your head.
Therefore, you should
always take into account
the user's orientation and
never freeze the camera
or force the user to
look somewhere specific.
If you want to grab
the user's attention,
use cues such as light
and sound to direct
them to look where you want.
You can also delay activating
an event in your scene
until you know the
user had turned
their head in that direction.
That way, they have time to take
things in and enjoy the scene.
You must always keep
to 60 FPS or higher.
Not only does it contribute
to a good user experience,
but it is even more
crucial in virtual reality.
Think about it this
way, the screen
is the only thing
the user can see.
Rendering at 60 FPS means
the user sees the same flame
for 16.6 milliseconds.
If you miss 60 FPS, vsync drops
you to 30 FPS and its frame
is shown for 33 milliseconds.
That means as the
user moves their head,
they're getting an incorrect
image for a very long time.
This is why it is very
important for virtual reality
applications to be
fast and responsive.
Movement can be tricky,
because the user does not
feel like they are in motion.
If the world starts
moving around,
it can contribute
to an odd feeling
if there is discrepancy between
one's actual lack of movement
and what the user is seeing.
There are ways to
convey movement safely.
For example, by
keeping motion constant
and avoiding acceleration, or by
using another object and making
it move first or creating
a path for the user to see.
This signals to the user
they're about to be moved
and subconsciously propels them.
There are many more ways to
ensure a good user experience.
I recommend you to check
out the Cardboard Design Lab
Application to learn more about
good and bad design patterns
so you can create the best
user experience in your game
or application.
Good luck with making your own
virtual reality experience,
and make sure to post about
it in our Cardboard community.